Happy to be here.
Real quick, Mr.
President,
think you'll
have some of your classified documents
that you get to be
getting there?
Don't give them to them.
I put them in a safe place.
He don't know where to keep them.
happy to be here, though.
Happy to be here.
Very happy.
Very happy to be here.
So it's a pleasure to be here.
Among our country's greatest lea
distinguished media organization
both property brothers and Dr.
Fauci,
if you see Ford,
you take a picture with them
that show new booster shots
which look good, though.
I've been I've been watching
and looking around all night.
You'll look good.
You dress nice,
you got the nice threads on.
You got the jewelry glistening
like everybody got a little piec
of the settlement money from Fox
and that's all I have to say abo
because I'm not going
to have dominion on my ass.
I love to me.
Matter of fact,
let me just say right now,
my favorite voting machine is
Dominion voting machines.
When I go to the polls, I
make sure it is a Dominion machi
that I use.
If your election need to true,
put dominion in your booth
let's
have going to get some
this three people
you don't want to see in the cou
That's Dominion
Cardi B or Gwyneth Paltrow you d
I like to thank
Tamara Keith
and the White House
Correspondents Association
for having your.
Thank you for that.
I'm well aware that not everybod
this room knows who I am.
So let's just address
the elephant in the room.
I know what it is.
Half this room think I'm Kenan T
other half
think I'm Louis Armstrong.
President Biden thinks I'm the d
Your family matters
nonetheless,
I'm happy to be here at this eve
Among government officials
who speak to MSNBC, former gover
officials who now work at MSNBC
and future government officials
who currently work at MSNBC,
an often overlooked
purpose of tonight's dinner.
You know, serious business.
The overlooked purpose of tonigh
dinner is to award
scholarships
to students
who have shown great achievement
in journalism right
These brave
young souls
are the future of the industry.
And I'd like to stop right now
and congratulate tonight's
top scholarship recipient,
Arizona's state singer Jorge San
Oh, yeah.
George couldn't be here tonight.
He's auditioning for RuPaul's Dr
That's not bad.
And we say good luck to you, Geo
Sashay away.
And also, speaking of drag queen
Tell.
Can we stop with the groom and s
Can you stop talking about the d
queens are not at a school to gr
your kids.
Stop it.
And even if they were, most of t
don't get shot at school.
Ain't no practice.
Don't grow, don't pass
legislation.
Like they booze.
Don't bother me.
I'm like, oh, my.
Mitch McConnell ain't got no sou
It's a tumultuous time
in the media, though.
We've got layoffs everywhere.
BuzzFeed News, NPR, Axios Washin
Post, ESPN.
Paramount Global
right now
is considering offers
from Byron
Allen and Tyler Perry to purchas
That's how bad it is out there.
These companies are so broke,
they're giving it back to black
which by the way, it's
not what we meant when we say
black people want it. Reparation
We met cash,
didn't give it to us and him,
Harriet Tubman to win us
But tonight,
we are all unified under one thi
And that scandal
scandals.
Scandals have been devouring car
this year, the untouchable.
Tucker Carlson is out of the job
Now. Okay.
Some people celebrate it.
But to Tucker's staff,
I want you to know that
I know what you're feeling.
I work at The Daily Show,
so I, too, have been blindsided
by the sudden departure
of the host of the fake news pro
Tucker that caught up,
got caught up
like that due from Vanderpump Ru
Text message said,
I don't know what Vanderpump
Rules is about.
I'm just watching a couple of ti
My friends told me it's like bei
left before, like people
was after the session.
No succession is power for white
No, Tucker
Carlson is power for white peopl
No, that's white power.
You know it. Never mind.
Don't worry about Domino.
No, about that.
We got to get Tucker back on the
President, because right now
there's millions of Americans
that don't even know why they ha
Fox claimed Dominion conspired
with the Democrats to rig the el
and the Democrats should be flat
that they thought
that y'all were smart enough to
an election
one that needed a run off
to beat a werewolf.
But it's not over for you.
Fox News is still that bad.
More bad news coming down the pi
That Smartmatic voting
machine lawsuit is coming, right
Smartmatic is coming for you
and they want more money than me
Let me just say right now,
my favorite voting machine
is the Smartmatic voting machine
And your election needs the trut
Put Smartmatic in your booth
But I think it's fair
that we should give credit
where credit is due.
Tucker Carlson is the first host
to get fired from Fox News for s
that's only
partially about how he treats wo
That's progress.
He shattered the asshole ceiling
Speaking of assholes,
Don Lemon is out of a job
Don Lemon,
my dog, Don Lemon.
Don Lemon
released a statement
saying he got fired from CNN.
Then CNN released a statement
saying that they offered Don a m
They had to part ways
because Don Lemon can't
even accurately report a story
about Don Lemon
I still think that Don deserve m
I think how you fired somebody,
that's messed up.
How funny is it
that you work in the news,
then watch on the news that
you got fired from the news.
Don Lemon
is now the most obnoxious guy
in the history of CNN. That's no
Even Jeffrey Toobin looking at D
like who?
He wrote me the wrong place
let him down, go was the wrong m
You shouldn't
have let him go, not just on CNN
First off,
Don was fine
when y'all was letting him drink
You shouldn't have cut off his l
You know, he your host,
after the first couple of scanda
like the stand,
the scandal has got to stack up.
You got to get you got to get ra
Yes. Don Lemon was a diva.
And he said a couple of
women are ragged in the face,
but that's a promotion at Fox Ne
But I ultimately understand
why CNN did what they did.
I get it.
It's about morals.
It should be no place on air
for someone who speaks
with wild disregard.
It doesn't consider the blowback
to their coworkers or their comp
Thankfully, CNN has taken
steps in the right direction.
We got rid of Don Lemon
and they've now given
a show to Charles Barkley
to Charles Barkley's cohost, Gay
We say good luck.
I think it's going to be a good
The whole show is going to be
Charles Barkley. Saying somethin
Then Gayle King looking into the
Charles
scandals
that's what connects us.
To so many scandals.
The king of scandals,
President Donald Trump.
Just for a moment,
can we just all acknowledge,
can we just all be honest
and just say that
the Trump address
didn't hit like
we thought it was going to hit
list?
Don't be sensitized to scandals
now that Trump addressed
it didn't do what I thought
it was going to do.
The trap for us
is like a pot brownie
you ate 4 hours ago.
You are Do I feel justice?
This will feel like justice.
Let me.
Traveling into the
Georgia arraignment,
Brown is made without a hint
of the governor's last gasp
taint followed Trump scandals.
There's too many Trump scandals
to keep up with
keeping up with Trump scandals.
It's like watching Star Wars mov
You got to watch the third one
to understand the first one.
Then you got to
you can't miss the second one
because he's got Easter eggs
for the fifth one.
Donald Trump is the only politic
who scandals got spinoffs on Dis
Plus
but the Trump arrests,
it made everybody question
what they believe
You thought you lean one way pol
Then Trump got locked up.
Everybody started waffling.
Put Republicans
between a rock and a hard place.
Donald Trump that locked up for
All Republicans.
I've been saying for years
we got to get tough on crime.
Trump got arrested. We met black
Same thing with the liberals.
Two liberals was all confused af
got arrested.
We got to abolish prison.
Trump got arrested, bring back r
I don't know about you all, but
the easiest scandal to follow
was the Trump documents scandal.
That was the one that was easy t
Simple is some stuff
that's supposed to be in the Whi
that ain't
in the media.
Y'all did Charles job.
Donald jumped on that story.
As soon as the Trump documents
story broke.
Everybody was down at Mar
a Lago
who is reporting live
from the documents, Tottenham.
And then we found out Joe
Biden had documents, too.
And it like it's not a big deal.
It's not a big deal.
Everybody got documents.
Everybody got back with Mike Pen
at some back.
Look up out of the oh,
look, the tiny spy balloon.
Would you look at that?
Oh,
well done, media.
Happy to be here.
Very happy to be here.
If there's one person
that could use the scandal,
it's Ron DeSantis,
that boy
just running around,
just passing every controversial
he can think of thinking that's
Activate bonus.
That's not how you activate vote
in this country, Ron.
Everybody know how you do politi
This is America. We don't pass l
You make a promise to voters,
and then you don't do it.
That's what
the great leaders
in this room understand.
You know how to make things not
The only thing the only thing Ro
DeSantis has done
that I got to give him credit fo
this boy
that got people riled up all the
they can't understand.
Don't nobody
they don't know
what critical race theory is.
Get these people riled up about
that they can't even define, lik
or NFT
as any Republican.
This anti CRT
in a Republican trying to explai
they sound like a Democrat
trying to explain
the charges against Trump.
It's bad everywhere.
He's got to stop it.
We've got to stop it. We got the
We got files.
We'll be right back. I'm Rachel
I have files
Rachel Maddow.
Get them files on you.
Just wrap
i think Republicans
would be surprised, man,
if you would just be real
about what CRT is that?
You can be surprised.
Some black might might meet you
But you got to tell the truth, y
A lot of black people call it wh
Anti CRT policies are an attack
on black history
and an attempt to erase the cont
of black people from the history
That's what it is.
You are trying to erase black pe
and a lot of black people
wouldn't mind some of that erasu
as long as that
black person is Clarence Thomas.
A
billionaire named Harlan Crow
flying Clarence Thomas all over
on unreported trips
like the Instagram model, taking
to the Maldives
and the beaches are no paperless
momma's house.
This billion to pay for Clarence
We got this house.
I got
I got to give it up
to billionaires, billionaires, B
y'all, y'all relentless. Yup.
Y'all always come up with
something new to back.
Like, just when you think of eve
you could buy on Earth from bill
will come up with a new thing.
Y'all about space rockets.
You bought Twitter
this this
man bought a supreme court justi
Do you understand how rich you h
to buy a supreme a black one?
On top of that
there's only two in stock
in Heartland Pro owns
half the inventory
we can all see Clarence Thomas,
but he belongs to billionaire
Harlan Crow,
and that's what an NFT is
everybody's got some scandal stu
Despite the challenging times we
I look around this room
and I see people that are hardwo
Many of you.
I don't even think you should be
that hard.
We should be inspired
by the events in France.
They rioted
when the retirement age went up
to 64.
They rioted
because they didn't want to work
Meanwhile, in America,
we have an 80 year old man
begging us for four more years o
begging,
begging
let me finish the job.
That's not a campaign slogan.
That's a plea
limitation, no definition
I do.
I do wish you the best of luck
on the campaign trail, Mr.
President.
You got a lot of things
that you're going to have to nav
a lot of hurdles.
You've had quite a few scandals.
You know, we
I know we know about the documen
we know about the laptops,
but there's been no scandal
more damaging than the scandal.
Love is Joe Biden.
The Awake
say what you want about our pres
Look,
when he
wake up from that nap, work gets
He might doze off with the infra
bill.
O student loan forgiveness.
Hey, do we free
Brittney Griner, free Brittney G
but I think the most insulting s
to fall
to the feet of the Biden adminis
was place at the feet of
our madam vice president.
The scandal of
what does Camilla do
which is a disrespectful questio
That's a disrespectful question
because nobody ever asked
that question
of the vice president
until a woman got the job
I'm going to ask
I don't know what Mike this be.
The only thing I know about Mike
is that he's really good at play
and seek at the Capitol
you've got to be crafty
to catch Mike Pence in that capi
heating the wall of nooks and cr
Don't put the camera on her
and the Mike Pence joke.
Don't do that.
Well,
he said he's trying to set you u
Madam Vice President,
at the end of the day,
as a vice president,
the only thing only you got to d
be better than Dick Cheney.
Gets the ball.
Just be better than Dick Cheney.
They made a documentary about Di
Cheney.
Now, I don't know
much about the job of vice presi
but I do know if they can make
a documentary
about your time as vice presiden
you vice president.
It incorrectly
and if a VP VP's job is really
just waiting
to step in to save the country
in case of emergency,
then the job of vice president
is a perfect job for a black wom
Shouldn't be, but it is.
And whatever you do accomplish,
whatever you do accomplish,
are you going to do it?
Just give a man credit for anyth
you do.
All the immigration stuff
you were knocked out,
didn't got all this banking,
and you got the internet down th
You're taking care
of all this postpartum stuff.
They just going to give a man cr
for what you done.
By the way, Mr.
President, great job
at being the first woman vice pr
of color.
I don't even know how you did th
Wonderful job.
Happy to be here.
But tonight
tonight is all about you,
all the journalists,
the defenders of free speech,
the people who show truth to the
through different mediums,
through television,
through print, through radio,
through whatever.
Trying to let us see you on Twit
but the industry
that covers all of these scandal
isn't immune to them.
They're self
the issue with the media is that
most people can't afford that.
All the essential, fair
and nuanced reporting,
it's all stuck behind a paywall.
People can't afford rent.
People can't afford food,
not healthy food.
They can't afford an education.
They damn sure
can't afford to pay for the trut
Same as you want
about a conspiracy theory, but
at least is affordable
listening.
Alex Jones
it goes you about not having to
and I understand that
we have to put this stuff
behind the paywall
because creating the truth is im
People can't afford the truth,
but you all can afford
to go find the truth.
For free.
The work you do as
journalists is important.
It's essential.
It's dangerous.
My father was an embedded
reporter on the frontlines
with black platoons in Vietnam.
He was in the South African Sowe
He covered that
the civil war in Rhodesia,
which we know today is Zimbabwe.
And my father came back
home and co-founded
the National Black Network
because he wanted to tell black
to American Urban
Radio Networks now,
and they've been doing it for 50
And that's part of what my fathe
wanted to do. You know,
and I know it was hard because,
know, black
dad is loved
telling you when something was d
They were shooting at me.
Boy, I
but I never dropped my tape reco
my daddy tell war stories
like Brian Williams
Lester Holt didn't laugh at that
Okay. So I don't know
good journalism, cos
that's the truth of the matter.
The journalism cost the people,
but it also cost the journalists
It could even cost you your free
We talked about,
even though The Wall Street Jour
sitting in a Russian prison
as we speak on espionage charges
which espionage charges, by the
that's the foreign equivalent
of saying someone fits the descr
Evan.
And hundreds of journalists
imprisoned all over the world
simply for doing their job.
We got to defend brave journalis
Most national stories in this co
at some point were first a local
and
those stories are
championed by reporters at outle
that many of them have now folde
If we can't figure out a way
to pay local reporters,
then as a country
we're only left
with that many more blind spots
to where the ball is happening.
You hear about all these newsroo
getting cuts.
I see every article that Tamra's
been sending me in
the last two months is just
the newsroom is getting cut,
cutting people with cutting budg
But you never hear about the mul
dollar executives
reducing their salaries
within these organizations.
Now, how do we fix this
I don't know.
I'm a comedian.
I was just up in
It's not my job to have the solu
that's only.
But local local reporting
is very important.
My mother is here tonight
and
I know she's furious right now
because I'm trying to put on cam
But my mother was among
a group of black student protest
fighting for equality in the six
At Delta State University and
and
that was a dangerous time.
But those types of incidents
were covered by local reporters.
And some of the shame
that came
from the national embarrassment
of treating people inhumanely.
It's part of the pressure
that helped to create
that type of change.
What would have become of my mot
and those of the protesters
of the local journalists
wasn't there telling the story
and now is no different.
But thankfully,
my mother's story was told
she got to complete a degree
at Delta State
and continued on to Florida
A&M and got another degree.
And then for the last 45 years
has worked
at a historically black
colleges and educator
and administrator and
one of those many black colleges
They need a little bit more fund
You've got a 20 on your job
here to send that down
to one of the black colleges
to my mom I say thank you
for everything you've done for m
and for helping countless studen
in Birmingham have the opportuni
to see a college degree
and to see an opportunity to gro
You know,
my mother's journey
may not have even begun
if not for brave journalists.
Who chose to chronicle
history in real time.
And I don't know how to ever rep
for what she's done for me
and what she's done
for so many people in Alabama.
But just know, Mama, if
if a white billionaire call
you an offer to buy your
house, please sell it
because I might want to become a
Thank you so much.
So the Correspondents Associatio
Thank you so much, Tamara Keith,
thank you all so much for not